in today's video we will be running from
an extreme tsunami this water goes
forever and it's terrifying and not only
do you have to outrun the tsunami but
you have to do an obstacle course while
you're at it it is terrifying it is hard
and which one do you want to go first me
pick me that was easy all right then it
looks like carl's going first wait
let's say hypothetically carl loses oh
that's not possible me and chris will go
to subway and order the most grossest
sandwich we can think of extra extra
extra mayonnaise extra extra extra
ketchup 500 stacks of bologna you get
the point last place has to eat the
grossest sandwich in the world press
that button and the tsunami will start
all right carl is off to the races his
time has began wait are there npcs or
something the npcs aren't what you have
to wear oh no
that actually took half my health whoops
carl watch out there's a tsunami coming
wait where do i go
you have the tools this is minecraft
carl you have to get to the end of the
course as fast as possible i'm doing it
i'm doing it why are you getting wood ah
stop about to die if this hits you it's
not my fault
oh it did hit me off the tsunamis
parkour over this carl
oh did i look kind of cool oh you did
look kind of cool
oh
i didn't mean to hit you carl it's
getting kind of dark
we can't sabotage it you can't stop me
stop you can stop me okay you can start
this my camera died you're talking to a
black image right now oh no
carl the tsunami's catching up oh not
the tsunami i can't see anything
carl the tsunami
[Music]
killed by magic carl you made it 200 oh
i don't have my camera hold up
my camera rebooted but now i look like
danny phantom oh my gosh you can see the
bone in my hand
everybody ready start the tsunami
go
hey chris
boink oh thanks
oh you guys just gotta stand up oh oh oh
oh okay all right you guys just gonna
hit me off ladders hey chris the tsunami
the tsunami chris of course all i'm
saying is if carl keeps sabotaging you
and he does lose oh my i would give him
an extra gross sandwich it's really
starting to lag now oh my god my jumps
aren't working carl huh do you know why
your shirt is ripped i don't know
because we have a sponsor state of
survival which is a mobile survival
strategy game based around zombies like
me it's 100 free to play and available
on ios and android chris you like zombie
survival games right yeah in state of
survival you play as survivors of an
apocalyptic disaster and not only that
but you also have to single-handedly
save mankind hey we do that on the
regular easy clap join an alliance and
choose to jump into immersive pve modes
and play at your own pace or test your
skills as a player and go head-to-head
with other players in the community
that's pvp data survival is free to play
and offers incredible in-game events
that give you the chance to win amazing
rewards those sweet rewards just keep
coming back other strategy games
typically only offer one game mode and
he gets repetitive and boring fast what
status survival isn't like that state of
survival has tower defense explore the
trail and so many other dope things you
can do in game and on top of all that
there's lots of hidden secrets in the
game so if you're like carl and a giant
nerd this is the game for you and i'm
giving away 50 free pairs of beast merch
to people that click the link in the
description and download state of
survival and if that's not enough state
of survival is giving away highly valued
starter pack if you use the link in the
description below just use code mr beast
sos and let's get back to gaming oh
there it is there it is if you guys mess
with me anymore i am going to die chris
it's getting close why can't i get up
not only is there a tsunami but you're
under fire oh carl i broke this for you
on accident yeah but i still broke it
for you
oh you freaking put a block over me
that's what you guys did to me chris
hurry the tsunami's here chris you just
have to make it further than carl chris
like if you break those blocks you might
beat carl by like one block there's no
way
ah and his score was 283 you are four
blocks behind him i have not lost i've
officially not lost there's a second map
carl don't worry you still have a chance
to screw up and lose no
oh he started he started he started
chris chris could you be any more
spiteful yeah
why why
that's so easy to get up no it's not
that's so awesome what's my name dream
i beat you with one arrow i hit you with
one arrow yeah and how many of those
times completely screwed you this game
is tearing our family apart oh he's
doing the strat
oh no oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
chris you can't do this there you go i
bet hey i helped you i've never had this
much fun
oh jimmy it's a comment
no no where are you gonna go jim jim oh
is he scratching oh my gosh you can't
stop
i want i hate you
oh yes yes oh no oh jimmy
turn around look at the water right
there oh no he's right here at the
finish jimmy it's right there go to the
finish line
yes yes yes
bada boom bottom bang gamers extra mayo
anybody hey for carl for carl wait how
according to the scoreboard i'm in first
place all right we got it it's your
channel and because i'm in first place i
have to go first on the second map go
begin this is the second oh wow alrighty
this is the second and final map
are you went in sun
oh i thought it meant oh yeah of course
you did oh my gosh we turn around look
how close the water is oh my uh uh it's
like a semi it says to go this way oh
there's a secret
oh thank you do you guys want to eat
mayonnaise sandwich we can't get through
the door
oh
gotta go hurry
uh-oh
how you going through that wait is this
a maze oh oh you went through the wrong
section
oh no
all right lovely that was carl come on
how was that carl
carl what the [__] i'm holding it on my
camera all right jimmy all right to the
right no to the right this way this way
this way you're good you're good you're
good you're good you're good right there
right there baby jimmy i'll help you
i'll help you there you go bud i did it
because i love you what are you supposed
to do here get away let me see what's in
the chest
so what am i supposed to do uh figure it
out oh wait so oh
oh
oh wait where's the oh what are you
owing about do something
[Music]
oh wait oh i should have no
i should have made a shovel i didn't
realize there was a wall of sand here
wait are you kidding me no you're
kidding me hold up hold up i got a
wooden shirt jimmy you gotta hurry
you've got to hurry oh i know what to do
but you might want to do it faster all
right i just got to grab this torch off
the wall you take the torch off the wall
and you do that yes all right big brain
bring great big brain how big bro it's
catching up
so i see
that was a pretty big brain play that
was actually five minutes wait is this
donkey kong oh don't worry the tsunami
is slowly coming here take a slow potion
you'll never oh you took me a lot thank
you thank you thank you thank you no no
no no no this tsunami's right there come
on oh
oh
oh no
let's be reasonable here let's be
reasonable here oh wait did i go outside
the map yeah you're outside the map
you went outside stop doing this i hate
you i finished
[Music]
all right carl's turn
ow
just press the button girl oh go go go
jimmy i do want to point out i really
didn't do that much to you okay
suck up no
carl it's coming in close
oh my god you got this carl oh hey carl
you're on you're on fire carl thanks man
am i killing it dude jimmy's going after
you carl oh the tsunami's so far away
carl you're good
oh it's actually close as hawk oh you
got it you got it you got it oh
tsunami's coming
here it comes carl this is all jimmy by
the way
[Music]
carl take your time the tsunami's so far
away stop
chris i will do everything in my power
in my power i'm not doing it i cannot
wait chris i'm not doing good i cannot
wait i cannot what did i do chris you
have to stop him this is jimmy this is
jimmy
bro you're so
you're cheesing so hard oh i can't wait
i i promise i can't wait this is going
to be the best day of my life when i get
to do this wow this is going to be the
best
swim carl there's five more blocks in
here above the water carl why would you
stop because i'm playing defense now
baby i can't wait
i can't wait
all right chris push all right here we
go
wait carl where'd you go
carl
he's gonna come mess with me
have some weakness wait why is mine
going so much faster
whoa what's wrong with me
we're gaming together now chris is
tsunami
well i can't make the jump why can't i
make the jump chris you gotta go you
have to go
the carl's just gonna cheat i guess
[Music]
your car you want me to unban you yes oh
chris
oh you're talking
cobwebs
oh now we're just killing it now we're
just killing it
i think i'm having a lot of fun because
i know i don't have to eat the sandwich
whoa that's cheese
cheese no no carl whackable
oh you guys broke it so i couldn't even
go anywhere go collect some materials
maybe huh that sand wall
hmm if you had 60 fours of sand
okay now we're just cheating you
straight up did that to me chris the
water's getting close
literally okay
you put a cobblestone block in the way
chris it's getting close chris oh wait
is your strat just to try to break it
one block at a time carl he's breaking
into the wall so he might beat you by a
single block wait what are you doing
where are you going
wait i don't see it
oh
wait oh did you swim up
oh he swam off
coral oh that is yeah whoa
you gotta eat the subway car i'm not
gonna do it we're gonna do tuna turkey
and then guacamole and then olives and i
want it all toasted you like honey
mustard
the bread's all soggy
how is it oh